oh
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir les efforts de macky sall
pour limiter les répercussions de la
guerre en ukraine sur le continent le
président sénégalais et président en
exercice de l'union africaine et en
russie il doit rencontrer vladimir
poutine ce vendredi objectif convaincre
le président russe de lever le blocus
sur les céréales en ukraine pour éviter
une crise alimentaire sur le continent
nous serons à dakar dans ce journal en
guinée un jeune homme est mort en marge
d'affrontements entre manifestants et
les forces de l'ordre il s'agit du
premier décès depuis la prise de pouvoir
du colonel doumbouya la victime est
décédée alors que des manifestants
protester contre la hausse des
carburants nous serons à conakry dans un
instant cinquante sept magistrats revue
révoqué pour corruption en tunisie une
décision du président queille cède qui
s'était octroyé les pleins pouvoirs en
juillet dernier cette révocation a
suscité de nombreuses réactions on fera
le point dans cette édition
[Musique]
permettre aux stocks de céréales bloqué
en ukraine à cause de la guerre de
parvenir sur le continent africain c'est
la principale requête de macky sall à
vladimir poutine le chef de l'état
sénégalais président en exercice de l'ua
l'union africaine doit rencontrer ce
vendredi le chef du kremlin macky sall
doit alerter vladimir poutine sur la
menace sévère de crise alimentaire qui
arrive sur le continent les précisions
de notre correspondante à dakar sa race
à cons pour
le président en exercice de l'union
africaine l'enjeu est de taille il
estime que le risque de crise
alimentaire est bien réelle les pays
africains on le sait sont très
dépendants des céréales d'abord mais
également des fertilisants produit
principalement en russie et en ukraine
et donc l'approvisionnement est perturbé
par la guerre et par également les
sanctions infligées à la russie macky
sall part donc pour parler pour la paix
pour porter la voix de l'afrique et donc
qui veut un retour évidemment une
accalmie
surtout plaidé pour la reprise de ses
exportations
le continent subit déjà très
concrètement les effets de cette guerre
depuis des mois déjà avec des prix sur
les marchés qui ont augmenté par exemple
ici au sénégal 80% des importations de
blé vienne d'ukraine et de russie
les prix de la tonne au flanc à a flambé
et c'est une hausse qui est compensée en
fait par une prime exceptionnelle du
gouvernement qui pèse donc sur le budget
en guinée voisine et bien hier mercredi
il ya eu 20 % en plus sur le prix à la
pompe le prix du carburant à la pompe
conséquence très concrète et en ce qui
concerne les fertilisants macky sall
estime qu'il pourrait y avoir une chute
dans les rendements de 20 à 50 % cette
année si le problème n'était pas résolu
il va donc évoquer tous ces sujets avec
vladimir poutine et dans le même esprit
d d'ores et déjà à une visioconférence
un rendez vous avec volodymyr zelensky
cette fois est prévu même si on ne
connaît pas encore la date ni les
modalités alors sarah le continent
africain est très dépendant des
importations céréales russes et
ukrainiennes c'est aussi pour ça que de
nombreux pays africains sont resté
neutre pendant cette guerre en ukraine
tout à fait en fait ils ont la position
de ce qu'on a appelé pendant la guerre
froide les non-alignés une position
assumée par exemple sénégal quand il a
fallu voter aux nations unies une
résolution condamnant l' invasion en
ukraine s'étaient abstenus une position
qui avait pu surprendre et que le
sénégal avait défendu en parlant de
diplomatie de la souveraineté il en est
de même pour une vingtaine d'autres pays
africains par la suite macky sall a
condamné l'invasion russe en ukraine ça
a été le cas fin mai dont qu'il a il ay
là il a condamné clairement mais ce que
l'on peut dire c'est que la position de
l'union africaine il l'a plusieurs fois
fait connaître l'union africaine veut la
paix elle n'est pas directement concerné
par ce conflit mais en subit les
conséquences on l'a bien compris et
voilà exactement quelle est la position
l'union africaine ils ne veulent pas en
fait s'aligner avec une partie où
l'autre pour la plupart des pays est la
preuve que la menace est bien réelle le
tchad a déclaré ce jeudi l'urgence
alimentaire
le 3e pays le moins développé au monde
selon l'onu pointe du doigt la
détérioration constante de la situation
nutritionnelle en raison de la guerre en
ukraine selon les nations unies en 2000
21 5 millions et demi de tchadiens soit
plus d'un tiers de la population avait
besoin d'une aide humanitaire d'urgence
et la situation s'est aggravée depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine en
bref deux employés de la croix rouge ont
été tuées mercredi dans l'attaqué de
leur véhicule dans la région de kayes
dans l'ouest du pays les deux victimes
sont le chauffeur du véhicule et un
délégué expatriés de la croix-rouge
néerlandaise ils ont été tués par des
hommes armés qui ont surgi à moto et qui
ont ouvert le feu sur leur véhicule
en guinée un jeune homme a été tué par
balles ce mercredi à conakry en marge
des heurts entre forces de sécurité et
manifestants des manifestants qui
protestaient contre la hausse des prix
du carburant une augmentation qui divise
entre colère et acceptation la
correspondance à conakry de manille
d'équité une soirée très mouvementée
pour les habitants de l'axé hamdallaye
bambeto cosa dans la banlieue de conakry
des jeunes très mécontent de cette
augmentation du prix du carburant ont
perturbé par endroits la circulation ce
qui a provoqué des accrochages entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
plusieurs médias locaux font état d'un
mort et des blessés depuis mes crédits
le prix des produits pétroliers en
guinée est passé de 10 mille francs
guinéens à douze mille francs soit une
augmentation de 20% une flambée qui
n'est pas sans conséquence sur le coco
dieu transformant le transitoire que
l'état n'ait pas augmenté mais nous on a
augmenté dans son assiette localement a
besoin on achète de carburant à dix
mille feux dans le temps
maintenant alors on achète à 2003 nous
j'en appelle aux transports à 2003
quatre ans à la population se plaint
beaucoup non à conakry des consommateurs
disent comprendre cette mesure
l'augmentation du coût du carburant
c'est
c'est vraiment à un niveau mondial il
faudrait que tous les guinéens essaye de
comprendre en tout cas par rapport aux
événements d'hier soir faudrait vraiment
qu'ils prennent conscience que c'est pas
seulement au niveau de la guinée c'est
au niveau mondial surtout avec la guerre
en ukraine donc il faudrait vraiment que
la population comprenne que voilà c'est
pas la faute au gouvernement de guinée
ans s'inquiète déjà de cette
augmentation du prix du carburant qui
selon eux risque d'avoir des
répercussions sur le panier des
consommateurs déjà très éprouvé la
nouvelle purge de cas et c'est dans
tunisie le président tunisien qui s'est
octroyé les pleins pouvoirs en juillet
dernier a révoqué hier 57 magistrats
pour corruption et entrave à des
enquêtes il avait également renforcée
par décret et sa tutelle de l'autorité
supervisant le système judiciaire une
décision qui a suscité de nombreuses
réactions les détails avec notre
correspondante à tunis lilia blaise
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour la
justice en tunisie quelques mois
seulement après la dissolution de
l'instance qui devait assurer le bon
fonctionnement et l'indépendance de la
justice le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
cette instance avait été dissoute par le
président de la république aujourd'hui
ses cinquante sept juges qui l'a limogé
pour des motifs d'accusation divers
aussi bien du harcèlement de
l'enrichissement illicite de la
corruption ou encore atteinte à la
sûreté de l'état ces juges ne pourront
faire recours à cette décision qu une
fois que leur affaire sera traitée par
un tribunal pénal c'est du jamais vu un
puisque en 2012 lorsque le ministre de
la justice de l'époque avait révoqué 82
juge pour motifs de corruption sous le
régime ben ali ces juges avaient pu
faire appel de cette décision au
tribunal administratif et pour certains
réintégrer leurs fonctions aujourd'hui
la décision de kayes sayyed a rencontré
beaucoup de réactions négatives au sein
de la magistrature mais aussi de la
classe politique qui accuse le président
de la république de vouloir renforcer sa
mainmise sur le pouvoir judiciaire
une ancienne juge kalthoum kanu a
déclaré que le président de la
république avait listé un parmi les
juges certains juges qui étaient propres
selon ses mots et d'autres qui se serait
opposé à kayes sayed par le passé un
avocat à qui j'ai pu parler à lui admis
qu'il y avait certains noms de juges
corrompus connu de tous mais que la
grande majorité restée pour le moment
innocente jusqu'à preuve du contraire
alors qu'on déplore leur disparition
ailleurs sur le continent il y en aurait
trop trop d'éléphants en namibie les
autorités du pays tentent de se
débarrasser de quelques 170 pachydermes
devenu encombrant pour les populations
ils ont été mis aux enchères ce qui fait
polémique depuis 2019 le traité
international sur la faune sauvage
interdit l'exportation des éléphants de
namibie du botswana et du zimbabwe les
op chars avec nos confrères de france 2
ces plaines du nord de la namibie les
éléphants ne sont plus les bienvenus
selon le gouvernement leur nombre aurait
considérablement augmenté de 7500 en
1995 à plus de 24000 aujourd'hui
conséquence la cohabitation est devenue
impossible pour les habitants qui
peuplent la zone et parce
qu'on regarde et il ya des traces de pas
il a avancé par là et il est resté
coincé est ainsi
maintenant je dois tout réparer
reboucher les trous
il y avait de belles tomates des
épinards j'avais de tout ici j'étais
prête à récolter et maintenant je dois
attendre à nouveau trois mois
des conflits qui ont poussé les
autorités à mettre aux enchères 170
éléphants
de quoi révolter les associations de
protection des animaux certains comme le
journaliste john crow blur enquête sur
la vente de ces mammifères en danger
d'extinction
fenêtre ces 22 éléphants ont été
capturés et garder ici pendant trois
mois après cela ils ont été transférés
par avion dans deux aux émirats arabes
unis il met les atouts de notre pays
entre les mains de propriétaires privés
c'est illégal
depuis 2010 9 il est en principe
interdit d'exporter des éléphants dans
des pays où ils ne sont pas présents à
l'état sauvage la namibie qu'il ne
respecte pas les conventions a bien
l'intention de continuer
au sénégal à l'occasion de la biennale
d'art africain contemporain de dakar
plusieurs oeuvres sont exposées dans la
rue à ciel ouvert le long de la corniche
ouest de la capitale une initiative qui
vise à démystifier l'art souvent
considéré comme élitiste les musées et
les galeries ne sont pas très fréquentée
par une bonne partie de la population
notre correspondant elimane dao et a
fait un tour au musée à ciel ouvert au
total une quinzaine d'oeuvres sont
exposées le lot de la corniche ouest de
dakar qui est à l'aune des a's axes
routiers les plus stratégiques de dakar
mais également un parcours pour les
sportifs et les promeneurs l'occasion
leur est ainsi offerte de découvrir des
oeuvres d'art qui d'habitude sont
exposées dans les musées et de les
interroger sur des thèmes comme
l'évasion le rêve ou encore la mort
cette initiative inscrite dans le off de
la biennale de dakar est très apprécié à
part les dakarois je vous propose de les
écouter ça fait
l'avionneur n'a pas eu lieu donc le fait
de voir les exposer trop long de cette
crise permettra certainement aux gens
qui ne sont pas imprégnés de se poser
des questions de savoir exactement
pourquoi s'est il ya du nouveau sur la
commune ça va nous permettre de s'évader
ça nous permettre d'oublier les soucis
moi et mes camarades on passe ici tous
les soirs pour pour se divertir quoi
pour moi c'est très intéressant en fait
surtout pour les gens qui des gens qui
n'ont jamais de s'intéresser à la salle
le pousse à s'informer au total 450
expositions sont offertes au public dans
le cadre de cette biennale avec des
expositions principal à l'ancien palais
de justice de dakar mais aussi au musée
des civilisations noires
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena merci à nos correspondants sans
qui ce journal ne pourrait pas se faire
et puis surtout merci à vous de nous
être fidèles restés avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]
vingt ans après la fin de la guerre
l'angola n'a toujours pas tourné la page
malgré le silence des armes les
stigmates sont encore bien présents
à nos fans ont fondu en larmes en boîte
ceux qui ont lutté pour leur pays se
sentent délaissés alors que la
corruption continue amplifier les
inégalités
mais une nouvelle génération semble
prendre le relais de la contestation
avec toujours cette même idée en tête
billet retour en angola à voir sur
france 24 et france 24 points comme